ilva ministers Commissioners
excellencies ladies and gentlemen a very
warm welcome to
Brussels we are here today because we
have heard their
stories we have heard the stories of the
survivors young men amassed in the back
of trucks across the desert with no food
no
air only a few bottles of dirty water
B young women abused over and over again
along the
Route we all have heard the stories of
victims of Migrant
Smugglers we have heard the stories of
Smugglers who got rich on the back of
their
victims and there are many other stories
that we will never know because they
ended in tragedy in the desert sand or
at the bottom of the
sea today we together here in Brussels
from different
continents and different
backgrounds but whether we represent
countries of origin of Transit of
destination for migrants we all share
the same
desire we are here to fight this
criminal
business to stop this
unspeakable
suffering we're here to build a global
alliance against the smuggling of human
beings we all know how difficult this
work can be but progress is
possible and where we have managed to
join forces within Europe with countries
near and far and with International
Organization progress is already
happening in September I was on the
island of lampedusa one of the gateways
between Europe and
Africa I saw the unsee worthy boats that
Smugglers are providing causing the
death of so many innocent
people I saw the dire situation of
migrants who survived the dangerous trip
I saw the incredible
solidarity of local people as well as
the
exhaustion of yet another crisis
since then we've managed to improve the
situation with hard work on a 10-point
plan we join forces with Italy un
agencies and
Tunisia crisis management is
important but it is not
enough we have to build a systemic
response that puts migrant Smugglers out
of
business and prevent the loss of
life and this is the logic behind the
anti-smuggling
operational
partnership that we have established in
these
years first with our friends in the
western Balkans who are not just
neighbors but future members of our
Union and then with some key countries
around our borders for instance Morocco
and
Tunisia but there is also room for much
broader Global
cooperation the criminal
organizations that manage migrant
smuggling are international in
nature they operate across borders All
Along The Roots that lead from the
countries of origin to the final
destination of
migrants we need to tackle every link of
these criminal chains their business is
often very
Diversified and half of the migrant
smuggling networks are also involved as
you know in traffic of drugs of firearms
and of human
beings they do not only exploit human
suffering but they also represent a
broader security
threat and this is why we want to
establish new bilateral Partnerships and
operational task forces focusing on all
routs where criminals and criminal trade
takes
place but we also need a Global Alliance
a Global Alliance with a common
governance and shared
goals it should be Global not only in
geographical sense but also in its
scope by focusing on
prevention on
response and on legal alternatives to
the deadly smuggling
roots and this is the spirit that has
driven Us in organizing this
conference the first track we will work
on is to
prevent and dissuade people from
entrusting their life to
Smugglers the best way to avoid violence
and death along the Route is to avoid
that the dangerous trip takes
place and this involves cooperation in
Border management and intelligence
sharing but as you all know also soft
tools such as information
campaigns and the new focus on so-called
digital
smuggling most irregular Crossings today
are advertised on social media they are
organized on messaging apps and they are
paid for by digital money
transfer and this can only be addressed
at the international level by working
with internet companies so together we
can prevent people from putting their
lives in the hands of ruths
criminals
second we must be tough and United in
our response to the CRI crime of
smuggling
we must all put in place the right
legislation we must get our law
enforcement agencies and
prosecution
services to work
together we must seize the assets used
by
criminals we must shut down the
International Supply chains and
financial flows of criminal
groups and we can only do this together
we all have something to learn and we
all have something to
share here in
Europe we are working right now to
update our anti-smuggling legislation
which is 20 years
old we will update the
definition of the crime of Migrant
smuggling we will toughen the
sanctions and we will extend our Juris
jurisdictional reach
we also want to improve the cooperation
between member states and
agencies with one single European
Center against migrant smuggling to
coordinate activities and share
information in
Euro we will set up operational task
forces including with partner
countries and europol will deploy staff
to reinforce member states capacity on
the
ground the smuggling networks are
constantly evolving but also must our
response constantly evolve and as we
update our own legislation to prevent
and respond to migrant
smuggling we also want to step up our
cooperation with you the international
partners and
here the United Nations office on drugs
and crime has a central role to
play you are the guardians of the UN
convention against transnational
organized crime which entered into Force
20 years ago in palmo and today we want
to support you even more both to
accompany signatories with legal and
technical
assistance and to bring more countries
on
board get whether we can make sure that
we all have the right tools to go after
these criminal
networks and finally but very
important we must offer more legal
alternatives to the people who want to
seek Fortune
abroad this is an interest we all
share in Europe labor and skill
shortages have reached record levels
in other continents there are millions
of
people who seek to work and
learn and we must manage this in a
way that it is safe Humane and mutual
beneficial with job matching initiatives
such as the EU talent pool which the
commission recently
proposed with circular routs where
people move train and bring their new
expertise back
home we
want but this Mobility must be managed
by the law not by The
Smuggler we are creating Talent
Partnerships with Tunisia with Morocco
with Egypt Bangladesh
Pakistan and we can grant more
opportunities for people to come to
Europe legally
this goes in
parallel to strengthen cooperation on
return of irregular migrants these two
need to go hand in
hand the better we are in legal
migration the more convincing we can be
in preventing irregular
migration ladies and
gentlemen most countries are at the same
time countries of
origin
Transit and destination for
migrants we're all
different but we are all together in
this and we can all learn from each
other so this conference shall not be a
oneoff
event we will set up expert groups at
technical level and take forward on the
three strands of the
conference we will then gather again in
one year from now and take
stock and this is the beginning of a
common
path and this is why we are
launching a call to
action open to all who want to join us
in this
Mission it is a call to all of
us EU institutions and agencies
governments and National authorities
International
organizations and online
platforms we need to pull our way
together if we are to be
effective and with the Global Alliance
we can start a new era of Corporation
and give a better chance to millions of
people ladies and
gentlemen in human history people have
always moved
but never before has the smuggling
business been so
profitable so
deadly human Mobility is a fact of
life migrant smuggling should not be one
it is a matter of political will it can
be
defeated and we only can succeed
together so I thank all of you for being
here today
and I very much welcome you again to the
International Conference to counter
migrant smuggling big success I wish you
for today thank you very much for your
[Applause]
[Music]
attention